hi my name is JJ Asghar and I'm a
developer advocate for the IBM cloud I'm
here today to tell you about what SEO is
I'm going to take it directly from the
website and move forward from there so
what is this to you sto is an open
platform independent service mesh that
provides traffic management policy
enforcement and telemetry collection
it runs on kubernetes Nomad and console
I'm going to be focusing solely on
kubernetes during this talk but you can
take most of it and actually put it on
Nomad and console if you need to before
we go anywhere else we need to discuss
something called a service mesh simply
put a service mesh is a network of your
micro services it is health service a
and service B you can talk to one
another and what is actually controlled
around there as your service mush grows
things get more and more complex and you
need to have a way to be able to control
how different services like service a
and service B talk to one another that's
where sto comes into play so let's talk
about the features of Ischia first
there's a load balancing this allows for
HTTP TCP any WebSocket trafficking where
you can actually control how
communication is done between service a
and service B or how things are coming
from the outside and there's fine
grained control to make sure that you
have rules retries fail overs even have
a fault injection you have a wonderful
world of how you can specifically talk
to service a and not service B in
certain situations there's also access
control to make sure that the policies
that you have for your cloud native
application is correct and is
enforceable and then finally the most
important part visibility you have
logging you have graphing things you can
actually put in front of them to be able
to see how everything is working it's
all for free comes together when you
install it's to you automatic metrics to
be able to actually do how you expect it
to make it happen so let's take a look a
look at the components of fist you I'm
going to start off with something called
pilot here which is as we like to say
drives the actual sto service mesh for
you it has the a/b testing it controls
the canary deployments the timeouts it
actually has the intelligence of a how
everything works
it is the driver of this view so let's
look at the next portion of the sto
architecture the next one is something
called citadel it is the security aspect
of your service mission it actually has
a CA built inside of it it allows for
service a and service B to be able to
talk to if they need to each other you
can actually upgrade unencrypted traffic
through your your service mesh through
Citadel to make sure that it is
encrypted going back and forth when you
start looking outside of just one
kubernetes cluster and you look into
multiple and extend your service mesh
across it sending things over the
Internet you probably want them to be
secure Citadel does that for you and
then finally there's something called
mixer it is the central point of where
all the side cars and all the ways the
sto works comes together it actually
puts the telemetry together to make sure
that it gets to pilot to be able to show
you those pretty graphs that we're
talking about earlier with the
visibility mixer is also a pluggable
total house for things to add other
stuff instead of just what sto gives you
there are other third-party companies
who have actually gotten their their
applications to work using mixture
specifically and that's the basics of
issed you you have your pilot your mixer
and your citadel if you like to get
deeper or learn more please go to the
IBM cloud blog I'm JJ and I hope to see
you around soon